saturday is kentucky derby day and if
you're looking for a watch party that'll
you know keep you in the spirit the
azilo ultra pool at sahara has you
covered with their special gifts and
cocktails sahara's director of beverage
nate headlined is here to show us how
the derby drink is properly done but in
a vegas way
with a twist right yeah so we're going
to make we're we're at the pool right so
we're at the pool we want a pool version
of the kentucky derby we got this giant
skate to watch it on so we need a giant
drink
like that one right there okay i love it
and obviously you know the derby drink
the official derby drink is the mint
julep do you have any idea why that is
um well people like to drink whiskey
down his house okay i like that that's
good enough for me
it's good enough for me and it's classy
right for the derby so let's make it
let's go ahead and do the demonstration
all right so old forester bourbon 86
proof that's going to be our main
ingredient right so this is a delicious
bourbon
recommend it for all of your mint juleps
and in fact it is the official sponsor
of the kentucky dinner okay great all
right so to make it official so i'm not
going to use a [ __ ] i'm a professional
i know how much i'm going to put in
there so okay let's take my word for it
i like that so i'm going to do two
ounces of old forester bourbon
oh i'll put some hair on your chest
derby too
i can smell it it's beach season so you
gotta be careful yeah it's very true all
right i'm gonna do one ounce of lime
juice
oh yeah okay for the flavor lozing so
what are we tasting here what it what
eventually when it all comes together is
it sweet is it so it's gonna be so the
special ingredient's to be this peach
puree so okay that's what makes it the
twist perfect marriage it's like morgan
mindy i like ross and rachel perfect
perfect
so peach puree so i'm going to do an
ounce of peach puree as well okay
this is good by the pool
and just while you're making this kind
of explain the vibe at the uh
zillow pool high energy so one of them
we're making it oh yeah make sure we
finish it now too this was gonna be your
part so i'm gonna put this together okay
and then you're gonna do the shaking all
right so then while i shake go ahead and
explain it so
like so okay here i go so a zillow pool
uh brand new car at the same time
um high energy big screen loud music
great uh
you're doing a great job yeah i was
listening kind of it's uh it's it's a
resort pool but it's got a party uh feel
to it so it's 21 and over the screen is
amazing i love it there the vibe
survives
okay so now we're starting it we're
going to put we're going to do the pour
i'm going to do the pork and you guys
look at this this is a giant drink how
much is this going for poolside so the
poolside one's 28 dollars
so very affordable yeah i love that and
it comes with a vibe and a party
i love it okay so how can people
actually join the the running of the
horse's watch party just have to show up
so we gotta add the soda to it first and
then we're gonna garnish it as well okay
look at me i was ready to take us
so some q soda on top
the bubbles is always important in
the soda that you use
would you like to add them in of course
this okay this is very official we're
adding the mint to the mint julep for
the kentucky derby i feel like and don't
be shy if it doesn't get used it gets
wasted so just make a bouquet out of it
gorgeous how's that it looks like a
little plant
and what's a kentucky derby
what's the derby without flowers right
everybody wears them yes or hats too
right you guys are providing hats
exactly that so
you can put the flower as a hat on top
of the drape that's very cute now tell
us about these hats you're providing so
we have a limited amount with old
forester they will be uh supplying
ladies hats so if you'd like to come
down
grab one celebrate the kentucky derby uh
we also are doing turtle racing so a fun
sport we're gonna have a competition
with uh super soakers so there's gonna
be this pool on the table and then you
gotta spray the turtle to uh oh
that's adorable i love that so it's fun
and games but also a vibe you got
everything something for everybody we
got something for everybody and there's
packages there's beautiful bungalows all
of that that's true yes okay okay great
let's go to the still so i can give you
the rest of the information the zillow
ultra pool's running of the horse's
derby watch party is happening tomorrow
from 10 a.m to 7 p.m you guys have a
website somebody we do
we do have a website so you can go to
the sahara las vegas website the zillow
link is on there you can read all about
it there if there's something that we
missed okay um and look forward to
seeing everybody in las vegas there
tomorrow yeah i love it and this drink
is delicious j.c i'll send it to you
sammy